Controlling an
autonomous vehicle
in order to accomplish a task
requires an understanding
of many aspects of the problem,
from the vehicle's dynamics,
to obstacles to avoid, to
the values of each objective.
It can be inefficient,
error-prone,
or impossible for
human operators
to specify a detailed
action sequence.
Thus, it is important to
elevate the level of commanding,
such that human operators only
need to specify a set of goals
to be accomplished and
then have planners produce
a series of actions that
achieve the mission goals,
based on the model of the
physical plant under control,
the environment,
and the objectives.
The planner integration
project combines
the capabilities of two planners
to provide a robust planning
framework.
We demonstrate the integration's
capabilities on Odyssey IV,
an autonomous
underwater vehicle,
or AUV, designed and built by
the MIT AUV Lab at Sea Grant.
The AUV has the ability to
dive, ascend, and glide,
as well as to take
pictures and CTD readings.
We can specify a set of tasks
for the AUV to complete.
The interface allows us to place
start and finish locations,
manipulate obstacles,
place waypoints, and enable
discrete actions such as taking
a picture or recording video.
Here, a user is creating a
simple task involving three way
points surrounding an obstacle.
After setting the
starting point,
the user specifies the
desired waypoint surrounding
the obstacle and also
moves the goal point
to the desired location.
The yellow edges
between the nodes
represent the high level plan
designed by the operator, which
crosses an obstacle in its way.
Kirk calculates the
first layer of the plan
to go around the obstacle,
shown here as the green path.
Finally, the red path
shows the complete plan,
which is the result of
Kong Ming refinement.
The AUV executed the plan
successfully in open water.
The final trajectory shows the
initial movement of the AUV
to the start, followed
by the wavy artifacts
from the control.
As a more difficult
task, the AUV
was tasked with drawing
a K in the ocean.
The AUV executed the plan
successfully in open water.
The actual trajectory is
plotted in Google Earth.
The Planner Integration
Project shows not only
the successful integration
of Kirk and Kong Ming,
but their interoperation with
a vehicle in a real world
environment.